depending on which archaeologist you
talk to
the ichneilled way is described either
as the oldest road in britain
or more carefully as one of britain's
oldest still surviving paths
it stretches more than a hundred miles
across southeast england
and there have been people walking parts
of this path since before
recorded history parts of it is still in
common use i drove here on the icmilled
way
for a couple of miles it was just a
regular country road
but parts of it were nearly lost forever
all over the english countryside you'll
see signs that say public footpath or if
you're also allowed to ride a horse on
it
public bridleway these are formal rights
of way protected by law
and there are more than 200 000
kilometers of them across the country
landowners do not get a say in who walks
along those paths and it's a criminal
offence
to block them the trouble is that some
of those paths have been lost
sure they might have existed once
historically the public had a right of
way
but they're not marked down anymore
there's meant to be a definitive map
but it's not complete it's almost like
the landowners at the time it was drawn
up
might have had a say in what was written
down back in the 50s and 60s
was when the legislation was introduced
to actually map public rights of the way
for the first time
but it was done on a local level so
there were definitely
um inconsistencies across area people
understood the guidance differently or
even in some small areas there might
have been local opposition that meant
rights away weren't recorded that should
have been so we've got an
incomplete network despite the icmilled
way being thousands of years old
legally opening every last bit of it to
the public took a lot of effort
not just research but also some fairly
militant walking enthusiasts
turning up at public inquiries this bit
i'm working on
wasn't marked on maps until the 1980s
as the 21st century approached the
government agreed that having these
maybe paths all over the country might
be a bad idea
in the year 2000 the countryside of
rights of way act opened
large areas of the country of open
access for the first time
but at the same time uh landowners
wanted some certainty about the rights
of waymap if they bought a piece of land
if there was a right of way on there or
not so as part of the negotiation
there was a cut-off date introduced and
that was the first of january 2026 and
that was basically
25 years on from from that legislation
so
we've got you know just under five years
to find all these paths and put them
back on the map
so now under law england has until
january the 1st
2026 to find and log all its footpaths
and as with any project with the
deadline that's a long way away uh very
little has happened
over the last couple of decades but with
five years to go the ramblers charity
decided to try and solve the problem
using very modern tools they asked
thousands of people
to check one bit of the map each they
were shown that square on the current os
map and they were shown that square on a
couple of
historic maps from about 120 years ago
and then we basically got people to to
draw on the difference to a big spot the
difference
we think we found tens of thousands of
miles of lost rights away
this isn't about creating new rights
away it's about recording ones that
should have been
recorded in the first place most
landowners understand that
the rights of wayne network bring
billions of pounds to the economy
each year you find a lot of farmers and
landowners like to use that public
rights of weight network as well
that is a very um political answer there
are certainly stories in the last few
decades of landowners
intimidating or bribing locals or
officials into just
quietly forgetting about some paths
there are plenty of people who would
very much like the public to get off
their land
and suddenly finding out that there's a
right of way through your farm
is often not going to be appreciated
they can only
really object on the basis of the
historical evidence
they can't object on the basis that they
don't want that part or that path is
inconvenient
but we really want to work with
landowners there's no point
from a walker's perspective a part of
just going through somebody's garden if
there's a way around that so
you know in some ways the real work
starts now and that's about
proving that that these paths were
historically probably right away
and actually submitting them to local
authorities so they can be put back on
the map
england is approaching a point that's
very rare in history
it started with the first concept of
owning land which was absolutely not
some human universal constant
then through the feudal system and the
idea of all land
ultimately belonging to the monarch then
to private landowners and folk knowledge
of footpaths
after all when most people never went
more than a few miles from home for
their whole lives
why would you need a map of the
footpaths everyone knew what they were
they were common knowledge passed down
from generation to generation
but now we're in an age of gps of
precise maps and of the expectation that
everything
will be on some database somewhere the
process of defining
who has the right to walk where in
england has been
going on for millennia since before
written history
but it ends soon january the 1st 2026
after that the definitive map is set and
there are no mysterious maybe footpaths
out there if the ignorant way hadn't
been marked
it could have been forgotten about
either it exists on the map
or it's gone forever it's not often that
you see a millennial
long process come to an end
thank you to jack cornish from the
ramblers and everyone who helped with my
research i'll put links to my sources in
the description
you